with so many new Netflix originals
hitting the service in August you'll
have more to watch than ever in the
coming month from wild new series to new
stand-up specials to a laundry list of
original films there's a lot to look
forward to let's take a look at what's
arriving and what's worth getting
excited about starting with the Netflix
originals switched August is kicking off
was switched a suspenseful Japanese
drama about a high school girl whose
life gets stolen by another student and
not just a life
her rival snatches a physical body
leaving her fighting to restore
everything to the way it was take a look
when switched premieres on August 1st
I'm a killer
true crime is blowing up all over
Netflix and the latest piece of fallout
is the upcoming series I am a killer in
this show the cameras are going into
death row for interviews of convicted
murderers some are remorseful others a
little lesser take the dive into
darkness when I'm a killer drops on
August 3rd
long live Brij Mohan stuck in a loveless
marriage and struggling under a mountain
of debts Brij Mohan doesn't have a whole
lot going for him so he takes the only
way out he can think of he fakes his own
death and worse starts his life with a
new identity but he can't run forever
and there isn't long before his past
catches up with him take a look when it
arrives on August 3rd cocaine Coast in
this Netflix series a poor fisherman
sets out to live the dream by shuttling
drugs between Spain and Latin America
getting filthy rich in the process it's
the story that's been told plenty of
times before but cocaine Coast looks
like has enough charm to pull it off at
least one more time
check it out on August 3rd like father
this Netflix film sees Kristen Bell
starring as an alter dumped bride who
heads out on the cruise to do a little
soul-searching what she doesn't remember
is getting blackout drunk with her
estranged dad after the wedding disaster
and inviting him onto the cruise with
her somehow I dragged him onto this
cruise that was supposed to be my
honeymoon now they're stuck on a ship
with nowhere to run except into their
tangled emotions it's just too bad they
hate each other like father sails onto
Netflix on August 3rd marching orders
you've sweated right through the dramas
of last chance you you've witnessed the
ups and downs of Friday night tykes and
cheered
young team into greatness with coach
snoop now get ready for a brand new
emotional journey with marching orders
when the players leave the field the
marching band takes center stage
marching orders follows the marching
Wildcats of bethune-cookman university
one of the country's biggest College
bands marching orders takes a field on
August 3rd mr. sunshine
this emotional series made its Netflix
premiere in early July 2018 but hasn't
made much of a splash with western
audiences quite yet the historical drama
follows a Korean soldier who lives in
the US for years before returning to
South Korea and falling in love with the
daughter of a high-class aristocrat with
both drama and thrills it's no wonder
that mr. sunshine has been gaining
popularity in Korea August will see a
new episode London Netflix every
Saturday starting on the fourth on
children with its strong black mirror
vibes on children looks like an
intriguing new show the trailer is full
of technological terror parallel
universes and memories swapping and we
honestly can't tell what's going on half
the time but it seems like a lot of fun
give it a shot when on children drops on
August 4th 72 dangerous animals Asia
Netflix's 72 dangerous animals series
take sanim Italy goofy approach to
nature commentary
a villain with a killer sting but one
that can also use its powers for good
the idea is each episode picks a handful
of similar dangerous critters runs
through their strengths and weaknesses
and then ranks them in order of danger
parts of flames to make way for fire ant
the newest entry in the series is set to
explore the rich world of Asia and all
the creepy crawlies who live there
look for it on August 10th the house of
flowers equal parts tally novella and
six feet under style dysfunctional
family comedy la casa de las Flores or
the house of flowers follows a family
that owns a flower shop even though they
you look perfect on the outside each one
of them has a dark secret just waiting
to come to light when the father's
mistress hangs herself with a family
store it opens the floodgates sending
all those secrets flooding into the open
it definitely looks like a fun darkly
comedic ride and you can check it out on
August 10th million-pound menu yet
another collaboration between Netflix on
the BBC million-pound menu is sort of
like a spin on shark tank where all the
hopeful entrepreneurs are going into the
restaurant business
it's high-stakes flame-broiled fun and
the whole first season hits the pan on
August 10 Scion this heartwarming
documentary follows Scion Clarke arrest
there at Kent State University who was
born without legs but Clark's motto is
no excuses so he's made it his life's
goal to not let anything hold him back
with Xion Netflix is taking a long
intimate look at Clark's life and the
inspired optimism that drives him to
continue to excel as a wrestler tune in
for the emotional journey on August 10th
insatiable season 1 after getting picked
on a whole life for being overweight
patty gets the chance to get back at her
bullies after spending a summer slimming
down that's the premise of insatiable a
dark revenge comedy that's already
garnered some online controversy based
on the trailer insatiable looks like a
violent comedic tale where anything goes
and the normal rules of the world don't
apply take a look when it lands on
August 10th all about the Washington's
fans of the hip hop group Run DMC are no
doubt familiar with Reverend run aka
Joseph Simmons who's also an on-again
off-again reality star it looks like
2018 will be another on-again year for
the Rev because he's coming back to the
small screen with a sitcom all about the
Washington's
Simmons stars as Joey an ex rapper who's
easing into retirement giving his wife a
chance to be the entrepreneur she always
dreamed of being along the way they'll
have to figure out how to keep their
wild family in check
look for it on August 10th the package
if we're being completely honest Netflix
as comedies can be really hit or miss
for everyone that's actually funny
you're bound to come across five I'll
just leave you groaning which one will
the package be all indications point to
what the former the dark comedy sees a
gang of teens heading out into the woods
for spring break
only for things to go horribly wrong
tune in for the high jinks on August
10th the Guernsey literary and potato
peel pie society based on the book of
the same name this mouthful of a movie
is about to write so who decides to pen
a perk about a literary Club that formed
during World War two while she's
researching a novel she gets caught up
in the story of the young man who
survived the occupation of the Guernsey
Islands falling in love with one of them
if the Netflix film is anything like the
book you can look forward to a whirlwind
historical romance about the power of
courage and loyalty find out when it
premieres on Netflix on August 10th
magic for humans caught somewhere
between a magic act reality show and
comedy series magic for humans sees
magician Justin Willman traveling around
performing illusions and telling jokes
in a new spin on street magic it sounds
like a great time and it premieres on
August 17th stay here from cooking shows
to travelogues netflix has been flooding
their service with great reality
programming on August 17th they're
adding to that lineup with stay here a
property fixer-upper reality show that
sees an interior designer working with
homeowners to spruce up their rental
properties the motive every writer needs
inspiration and then the motive it comes
from some pretty dark places the movie
focuses on Alvaro
a wannabe writer who moves into a new
apartment after a divorce there he
begins manipulating his neighbours to
use him as inspiration for the
characters in his book as you might
expect things get out of control pretty
first part comedy and part thriller the
motive arrives on August 17th
ultraviolets this polish drama centers
on Ola a woman who watches a bizarre
accident and fold unable to accept the
police's verdict but the accident was a
suicide Ola begins to dig into it on her
own leading her to stumble across
a secret online community called
ultraviolet a group of Internet
vigilantes who tackle the cases of
police can't solve
TuneIn for all the twists and turns on
August 17th disenchantment season 1 by
the time the first teaser for
disenchantment dropped the internet was
already buzzing about the show from my
graining creator of The Simpsons and
Futurama disenchantment is set in a
fantasy world and promises all the same
humor fans of gradings other shows have
come to love butcher shop take a look
when the first 10 episodes of
disenchantment land on August 17th - all
the boys I've loved before this teen
drama follows Lara Jean a high school
girl it was an unfortunate habit of
writing long secret love letters to all
our crushes it's unfortunate because out
of nowhere all those letters end up
getting mailed out to the boys in
question turning Lara's high school life
into a circus of unexpected attention
the upcoming movie is based on the
popular book of the same name and drops
on August 17th the investigator a
British crime story season 2 now flicks
his popular true crime offerings like
making a murderer the staircase and evil
genius tend to get all the attention but
the real crime is how overlooked some of
their other series are case in point the
investigator this British true crime
series dives into some of the most
enduring mysteries of the UK with the
second season the show is holding its
focus on two serial killers and their
possible connection to a rash of
unsolved murders take a look on August
19th dead wind after this series swept
Finland them became something of an
overnight sensation
Netflix swooped in to grab the
international distribution rights like
they often do in this case it looks like
a great decision a series follows a
grieving detective who gets caught up in
a murder investigation just two months
after the death of her husband leading
her down a spiraling path of violence
and grief for anyone looking for a dark
suspenseful show to get caught up in
dead winds looks like it's just the
ticket
tune in on August 23rd the after-party
get ready for a musical roller coaster
with the after-party
California rapper Kyle Harvey stars in
his hip hop infused comedy about a
rapper on the outs with this fans who
gets one final chance of redemption
check out the after-party when it drops
on Netflix on August 24
the innocence season one Netflix has
been dropping teasers for the innocence
for months now but none of those
trailers have revealed a whole lot about
the series actual story apart from some
hints of a bizarre plot involving a girl
who turns into someone else we really
have no idea what to expect
regardless the innocence looks like a
seriously twisted show with amazing
production design and a fantastic cast
take a look on August 24th ghoul it's
been a while since a good new horror
series showed up on Netflix and it looks
like ghoul is set to break the dry spell
the show is set in a secret government
center where one of the prisoners may be
a little more demon than human plum
house a company behind movies like get
out on the purge is producing the
three-part horror extravaganza which
lands on August 24th ozark season 2
it's been a long the bits awaits but
fans of Oza can finally see a glimmer of
hope on the horizon the show which stars
Jason Bateman as a financial advisor
caught up in the underworld of drug
trafficking was nominated for a Golden
Globe and quickly built a legion of
dedicated fans it's both dark and
humorous violent and surprisingly
heartfelt and we're all hoping for more
of the same in season two floats on to
Netflix on August 31st the laws of
thermodynamics written and directed by
Spanish filmmaker Matteo Gill the laws
of thermodynamics is a typical
boy-meets-girl scenario but with a
science twist the core romantic story is
wrapped up in theories about how
scientific laws also affect
relationships and emotions
it's a strange armor cross over sure but
one that looks like a decidedly
interesting viewing experience
look for it on August 31st ultimate
beasts master survival of the fittest
strap on your sweatbands and settle in
for the riders ultimate beast master
survival of the fittest leaps onto your
streaming queue the fit and fun
competition will see a whole new lineup
of contestants facing some of the most
challenging obstacles to date with
plenty of dramatic commentary to keep it
exciting it's like
transformer and Godzilla had a baby or
something you can catch all the new
episodes on August 31st new stand-up
comedy keep your eyes open for a handful
of brand-new comedy releases hitting
Netflix throughout the month on August
10th at Demetri Martin takes the stage
with the over-thinker riffing on topics
ranging from road rage to horoscopes to
being the kind of guy who overthinks
everything then on August 24 that look
for Bert Kreischer secret time followed
by part two of Netflix's recent comedy
series a comedy lineup which sees
multiple comics taking the stage for
Shore 15-minute sets you'll be able to
stream that on August 31st about saw the
Netflix originals arriving in August now
let's take a look at all the other
movies and TV shows hitting the
streaming service new movies the best
part of each month Netflix lineup is
invariably the addition of a brand new
slew of old favorites and August is
bringing plenty of classics on the
action front look for films like Batman
Begins Constantine and 1985 western
Silverado all of which show up on the
first you can't do this freely there are
also plenty of laughs to look forward to
this August with classics like Steel
Magnolias clerks and stripes shouldering
their way onto Netflix on the first on
the 16th you can sit back and watch
Steve Carell build a biblical boat in
heaven Almighty and on the twenty first
witness Jack Black's a Michael Cera epic
journey across prehistory with the
slapstick comedy year one guys trying to
enjoy the sacrifice with my family
you might chances are none of those will
particular your Terrebonne but don't
worry August is also bringing
dreamcatcher which you can catch on the
first along with chernobyl Diaries about
some mutants on foolery at the Chernobyl
nuclear plant finally follow that up
with a 2015 horror film Emily on the
second what's not to love new television
it'll be a good month for bending your
favorite shows us August highlights for
this month include season 5 of the
originals on August 9th season 5 of the
100 on August 15 and season 5 of young
and hungry on August 24th fans of the
heavenly comedy the good plays will also
have a reason
to look forward to August which sees the
arrival of the second season of the
emmy-nominated show when she's
accidentally sent to the good place
Elinor decides that there's never been a
better time to try to be a good person
and actually earn her spot there look
for the second season on August 28th
[Music]